Speaker 1: So many of you wrote to me about
anti-vaccine diamond of diamond and silk
fame dying of COVID and everything we know
right now does suggest she did die of COVID,
although there are still remaining questions
over this diamond and silk were this duo
of Trump supporters who became sort of
well-known because Trump promoted them
and would sometimes invite them on stage.
They were vehemently anti-vaccine. They also
were confused about a lot of different issues,
including the price of mangoes, as many of you
know. But that's a completely different story. The
belief right now is indeed that the death was the
result of COVID. They were very aggressively
anti-vaccine, which we will talk about,
AP reports Diamond of the pro-Trump duo Diamond
and Silk Dead at 51. Lynnette Hardaway, an ardent
supporter of President Donald Trump and half of
the duo Diamond and Silk, has died. Hardaway,
known by the moniker Diamond, carved out a unique
role, I'll say, as a black woman who loudly backed
Trump. Her promotion of COVID falsities eventually
got her dropped from Fox News, but she landed on
another right wing cable platform. The pair's
verified Twitter account asked people to quote,
Please pray for Diamond in a November tweet, but
did not elaborate on the circumstances. Newsweek
reports. Was Lynnette Hardaway's cause of
death COVID? What we know what we don't.
On Monday evening, the duo's Twitter page
confirmed Hardaway had died but asked for
privacy and gave no information on the manner
of death. The article goes on to say Some social
media users claimed Hardaway died from COVID,
but it has not been confirmed by the family or
her group page. Many of these claims are made on
the basis of a report from the website blavatsky,
which now appears to be unavailable. Daily
Beast reporter Will Sommer highlighted the
tweet. I'm seeing claims that diamond of
Diamond and Silk, a COVID vaccine hater,
died of COVID and was hospitalized for it. But the
truth is, her cause of death isn't clear yet. And
the November claims that she had COVID came from a
bladed article that appears to have been deleted.
MAGA supporter Diamond of Diamond and Silk has
been hospitalized due to COVID was reported in
November, but that is based on that underlying
report, which now is unclear as to its truth.
What we do know is that Donald Trump put out
a statement about the death of Diamond saying,
quote, Really bad news for Republicans. And
frankly, all Americans are beautiful. Diamond of
diamond. And silk has just passed away at her home
in the states she loved so much. North Carolina
Silk was with her all the way and at her passing,
there was no better team anywhere or at any time.
Diamond's death was totally unexpected. Probably
her big and precious heart just plain gave out.
Rest in peace. Our magnificent diamond. You
will greatly. You will be greatly missed.
Trump speculating about the cause
of death as well. And as a reminder,
here was their view about COVID vaccines.
Speaker 2: Yes, we don't need to look at the
immune right, but what we don't need to happen
is what happened with Africa. When Bill Gates
and them took that vaccine to Africa trying to
vaccinate, they felt like stuff can start right
there and start in parts of Africa. That's what
we don't need to. You not don't make black people
not a guinea pig. But if we're not here, be your
experiments, not your your project. Right. Not
black. Yes. Today, Bill. Yes. The sergeant the
sergeant general was talking to. As a matter of
fact, he was trending today. Listen, I tell
us what we need to know. Yeah, but I always
look at the underbelly of what's going on. My
intuition in me. That's my intuitive counterpart.
Yes. Uh huh. What do you want to do here? Right?
Because what you not going to do? You're not
going to start vaccinating black folk, right?
And we have to have a vaccination card just to
go to get there. You're not going to do that. And
what it does, it it'll start with us first, right?
Speaker 1: I think you get the point. So, listen,
unclear if she died of COVID. The team's voicemail
is related to the death of Diamond. I take
no pleasure in anyone's death, vaccinated
or unvaccinated. I never have a Donald Trump Jr
and others claim people on the left want right
wingers to die of COVID or to die unvaccinated or
vaccinated or whatever. That's absolutely insane.
There is absolutely no evidence whatsoever that
I take pleasure or hope for the death of any of
these folks, whether it be Herman Cain or whoever
else, if indeed it was a death from COVID and
she was unvaccinated. That is a tragedy. It's a
tragedy of weaponized disinformation, although we
know that against the new variants, the vaccine
does not prevent transmission or infection. It
does reduce the odds that you die. And it has
likely saved tens of millions of people globally
and whatever the circumstances are of this
death. Although I found her political views
disgusting and deplorable and contradictory to
everything I stand for, I do not wish harm on
anybody. And we will, I believe, at some point
find out the truth about the death of Diamond.